nellis air force base opened their gates
today for an interactive tour of their
facility in the midst of a pandemic
and 8 news now reporter madison
kimbrough stopped by to learn how our
local air force
is dealing with the recent changes of
cobit 19.
nellis air force base is on a mission to
strengthen its ties with the community
a lot of different activities and today
they welcomed local media to tour their
facility and flight line to get a better
understanding of how things operate
during a pandemic
we've all been going through coveting
the associated challenges with respect
to the very important mission here at
nellis that that means kind of a
tactical pause and reset and looking at
what we
what we need to do to implement to keep
our force safe
and healthy that also includes making
sure that people keep their distance
the air force base also provides plenty
of cleaning products and hand sanitizer
stations
along with mandatory masks on base while
good health is vital to all
for those at nellis air force base their
facility is the leader of american air
power training
so following protocol for covet 19 while
still being able to follow their mission
is key things we do here you simply
can't do anywhere else in the world
commanders of the 99th air base wing
57th wing
nevada test and training range and the
virtual test and training center were
all in attendance today
offering insight and showed off their
flight line with their f-35 and
f-16 aircrafts reporting from nellis air
force base madison kimbrough 8 news now